did you ever try sticking up with your
dad yes you know my dad oh i was too old
for her
i was too afraid my dad's a tough out my
dad was so much bigger i'm tearing mine
too i'm terrified of my dad i was
and i remember all the kids were getting
notes from their parents to take uh
their senior year to take it off the
ditch and i asked my daddy it's not
happening you got to be in school man i
go
dad everybody's doing it it's not
happening i go i'll [ __ ] it i'll do it
myself and walked away
and i'd never disrespect my dad ever oh
dude i'm
[ __ ] i'll figure out myself i walk
away and i just hear a
through a [ __ ] pen what the [ __ ]
i gotta turn oh my throat against the
holy [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah there's uh you you've met my
dad but here's it no your dad's your
dad's a very big guy
superintendent stays in shape he's in
better shape than that my father was
just a giant irish guy who i knew
there was a there was just a point where
i was going to get my neck broken you
got to be careful i i i'm not a big guy
but senior i was getting recruited
here's what you'll find out because your
kids are going to be big right
high school or college high school
here's what you find out you find out
real quick as a
as a father and this is my dad because
when jacob challenged me to fight i
called my dad
and i'm like what's the deal cause i
remembered fighting we all i had three
older brothers we all took a turn to my
dad
we re i remember vividly my oldest
brother getting us all pumped up i'm
gonna go fight dad we were all behind
him like yeah let's go get him get his
uh yeah let's go get him come on we're
gonna
wait and he was like i'm gonna make the
rules in this house so you're like yeah
you're gonna make the rules
you know we were all behind them you
know because he's the big brother he's
unbeatable in all right yeah
and he walked out back and my dad was on
the porch smoking a cigar
like what and my brother comes out and
goes hey we're fighting today old man
and my dad goes okay and he stands up
and my brother goes let me tell you
something and before he could get
another word out of his mouth my dad
just
kicked him in the nuts harder
i wasn't but then
right like that right and he dropped to
the ground and my dad takes a puff out
of the cigar and he goes
don't talk when you want to fight son
and walked inside the house and i was
like
oh this dude's a [ __ ] guy he goes
anybody else dude
and you know why i knew he wasn't
worried he didn't never took the cigar
out of his mouth
he was if you don't take a cigar out of
your mouth going into a fight
even my son even my son at four attest
me dude he's gonna test him oh go you
don't think i'm strong i'm like papa
you're never gonna be stronger than me i
guaran you're
never gonna be here yeah you he may not
be my album and i just twist them
and he might stop what if the two of
them gang up on you it's gonna be
problems
my father my father because he's just
such a big guy's name was so big so he's
going to be stronger bigger than you
he's six fourteen his dad's huge six
four two fifty your dad is six four two
he's gotta take size 14 shoes he's in
there too wide uh he has to get he's
he's got wrists like this do you have
brothers and sisters no i have a sister
dad have a seat
he he my dad my dad's got he's probably
got a piece but my dad um
i remember i was wrestling yeah yeah i
got i i got him beat
but um my dad uh
by the way i just i'm not gonna tell you
who but i did hear stories
who said i've seen brian's [ __ ] in the
bathroom at the
i'll send you a picture no i'm good yeah
i'm good he said to me though
but can i take your word for it you know
let's take your word yeah would you say
yeah yes happy wednesday it's just his
flaccid old [ __ ] just thanks
i do well it's like this dude it's no
it's good but he is
i was wrestling and working on my neck
no yeah i'll send i'm going to
because you talk about your [ __ ] body
and your plant-based shake but
i put my neck against my dad i was doing
i was wrestling and i was doing neck all
my neck stuff like that i have a strong
neck because yeah my mother said your
neck looks thick and i was like
a thick neck and i went i went let's see
whose neck is stronger and
we were he was getting ready and we were
in the garage and i put my head against
his to see who could move
their head and he went like this he just
went and he doesn't exercise and he went
like that
and i went i went hold on let me try
again you know when guys beat you in
arms yeah
let me try again like that let me go and
he goes like that again i go he's so big
how are you doing that and he goes i
don't know i have a strong neck he
doesn't have a neck
he has a head and he's got a head and
shoulders yeah so so it was so
interesting for me to get
be it's like when you arm wrestle dudes
who have um
they're just bigger popeyes yeah you're
not beating them i just want to let you
know that
i as a grown man i don't arm wrestle no
me neither is too dangerous
yes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do
use some of that boxing you've been
doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected